during during that party like your close
friends a lot of people are cutting it
really bothered him in ICU this text on
your home tonight a lot of people come
up to me and go man god [ __ ] I'm so
thankful Brian May it's so cool man he's
killing it and then don't do it all
thank God you and Brian met thank God
for you and I and it started pissing off
I told you I'm like for one more person
says i'ma freak out and then we got home
like I don't and you would know the
dynamic of you and your family but it
really bothered me because I was like
what the [ __ ] are they talking about if
you look at things thank God I met Brian
Allen I was getting punch in the face
for a living Brian was doing just fine
before I met him but there's no fighting
the kid there's none of this happens
with one without the other that's just
not that's just not but it's it's I
don't know him it was a weird bottom i
think that long text I was like you know
everyone here was a panic attacks and it
drives me I let you know you really have
to drive me nuts I let him read that
text cuz I was very very moving tag and
what I I think what I say a lot of times
is like we know you think I said it in
my ebay [ __ ] out yeah like you would
think before your this complete [ __ ]
you want raw attic just didn't have [ __ ]
going on and then I find you on the
street I'm like hey man you want to a
podcast right yes I'm like this what
we're gonna do follow me you know I'm
saying that's not the case at all it was
more me crying the locker room after UFC
180 one leaves in a fight good what the
[ __ ] am I gonna do and you going this is
what we're going to do you want to see
the Anderson Silva you know Anderson
Silva wants to box are not box fight
conor mcgregor a women entertainment
what why you want heart it well remember
i was in silver was Anderson Silva with
the original guy who went to box Roy
Jones jr. and they even had an agreement
and this is I mean since Roy by six
years ago so still no Leroy Jones but
you know that that matchup will makes
more sense than for a rich Connor
style-wise but they're both so you know
they're older yeah and an answer was in
his prime and yeah and Roy was not and
remember they had it contractually ready
to go but dynamics
let him Wow and it's a good foot taller
mr. different it's crazy yes weird yes
Evander Holyfield one for them too and
I'll talk hahahaha that's a true story
no I swear he can manufacture all right
guys everybody calm down hey real quick
that's how big of a star your dealings
nuts Manny Pacquiao's for a rocky
Evander Holyfield and Anderson he still
plays on more famous than all of them
yes yeah but don't you see him out mama
second hey Tata has even acknowledge
those guys no other what your event
matter what if I told you lady Ria's
came out and ugly I've I'm all for some
nettle stiff I'll fight on just bankrupt
this [ __ ] like where's the highest
suicide rate in this country Seattle and
their dentist in the nation that's not
bad Seattle Wow where'd you guys say you
said their dentist you dentist has a
high suicide row like job on QB like
yeah like patient well if the American
West you didn't know that no I'm just
gonna [ __ ] teeth all day the American
school forever think about it yeah so
should we get some chompers like you
like the guy who's gonna do Collinsworth
any bomb teeth yeah he looks at because
oh my god there goes my day oh my my day
okay I wicks you're the [ __ ] there he
went commit suicide yeah buying I
companies like you tease liner mmm-hmm
and that might be a thing that does it
well yes optical it's right there
looking at my moms like looking at war
it's a lot of work flying to its all my
camy any teeth letting us yeah he's just
like so overwhelming my dentist starts
to weep right mix in my mouth elders and
I sure on my dick and he's got to laugh
all right now ah I don't were saying how
we know what's going on either a nothing
is tiny is it some people play grab-ass
and we know a lot of girls like this
like there's a hot girl and they go on
auditions maybe these actors or
comedians or whatever and it doesn't I'm
working up in that 50 you seem at a
coffee shop with her titties down to the
ground yeah [ __ ] bad choice tattoos
all over the body and just never
worked out that's right and that's
always a tough one it really is man to
make a mean cup of joe though and God
bless them they make a mean Cumberland
have a tea no they suck don't say it
don't say it out loud to the light
that's the life out of you if that
coffee thank you that's what I would you
say if I make a mean cappuccino and then
they will suck the life out of sauce the
life at yo D no I can't why did you have
to say next lecture dunno like okay that
like a corn dog on a hot summer day and
it is true but don't stand out practice
makes perfect and after 50 years and bad
decisions and horrible tattoos yeah and
one hell of a cappuccino you learn
something well when you're fit one skill
you picked up in LA sucking well when
you're 50 and you've been here since you
were 27 you have girls I put some
numbers as you know I've gone through
some numbers bub and I've gone through
some numbers and a lot of those numbers
were when I was in my 22 my 30s and
those girls were too delicious on the
streets they call you the white mamba
they call me the white mob out of
numbers I put up some numbers put a
point straight up ass ass at a point
let's try to push the assassin yet hey I
mean a plate roll that I thought you
said I said white mall that's another
one called osseous what have you just
said nobody i could you wipe mama why
mama a que por judas Robin hey why model
white neck I'm not saying it's what you
said you said we said why mama AK [ __ ]
assassin that's what you have to put
your mouth it I think I do the white
assassin game to my mom does your
shooting rope I'm sure I shoot heavy
ropes although now i'm older and it just
kind of comes out and dribbling why
don't call you why mama now now we're
gonna drop his man i got kids now you
call me guy with a guy creepy guy with
wife two kids who goes when hot girls
come by and it's simple mathematical
equation right you have your expenses
you have your overhead you have your
anticipated profit or revenue and if you
don't do all the math beforehand and
you're paying you know three times what
you should be paying primers naturally
you're not going to be able to pay the
next show because you're still catching
up on the previous show and that's a lot
of shocked about like I you just oh [ __ ]
are you serious is that the full office
or just a whole
uh Howard just shut off in the in the
official funny kid big brown studio the
entire office building has been shut
down but when it's not fight camp and
it's not time to train for a designated
date they're not they're nowhere to be
found near the gym you know and they're
all you know vacations getting drunk
doing whatever and I'll tell you and
I've always said this that Leo toe is
someone who whether you know training
for a fight camp or whether it's you
know one hunt like this right now you
know year plus suspension and in no
fight in sight this guy's as dedicated
coming to the gym keeping a regular
schedule training and absorbing jujitsu
and dedicating to the actual learning of
the art and I feel like without a fight
date set right now because we're not
training for a particular opponent he
just became a student again from scratch
of jiu-jitsu and be fascinated with his
own growth and I'll tell you right now
the hype is that Leo toe is you know
taking necks and cashing checks right
now at the academy and you know he's
just learning growing and students are
noticing like yelled ahead of this guy
in the last 12 months he's gotten way
better guys do you not only train with
him once every three or four months
they're like right now this guy's
tapping me out way more than I ever
anticipated he's much more annoying to
to grapple and to roll with so it shows
so cool to see someone who just at the
top of their game continues to be such
an avid student of the arts and and
that's a large reason why he is where he
had visa lifelong martial art a lot of
these fighters yeah I come in later and
you know like you said for our family
doing it from the diapers it's the same
thing for them and he's not just with
that with karate but every art he does
he just immerse them so for both you
guys for little to you mentioned to me
when we were training says the lifestyle
like he was always on like you just take
a break go somewhere I gets a lifestyle
this is just what I do and that resume
would mean so much like that eats right
he's such a student of the game can do
it for every think it's a lifestyle yeah